est ce la légendaire douceur du climat
loin du tumulte du quartier latin la
touraine a elle aussi connu son mai 68
pas de barricades pas de pavé pas de
violence ou si peu mais des soubresauts
de l'histoire sociale qui ont
durablement marqué les esprits avant une
grosse et dont la société et le
lendemain on vit si j'avais un bilan à
faire
je souhaiterais qu'ils reviennent vite
aujourd'hui sincèrement on voulait pas
prendre forcément le pouvoir on en était
incapable bien sûr à la preuve les
hellènes au suivant le monstre on
sentait alors une possibilité un avenir
autre
préavis de grève grève ptt avril mai
juin à tours aux archives
départementales archivistes et historia
ont patiemment collecté trié indexés et
analyses et les multiples documents
d'époque photos articles de prêt ce
tract aux pièces administratives autant
de traces permettant de reconstituer les
événements tels qu'ils se sont déroulés
en touraine
pourquoi nouveau projet de la fac de
lettres jean royer député maire nous
donne son opinion en ce début de
printemps 68 la pression monte dans la
jeune université de tours au malaise de
la jeunesse qui étouffe dans une société
corsetée s'ajoutent des conditions
rendant les études difficiles ceux des
conditions matérielles qui sont jugées
insuffisantes
le nombre d'enseignants puis il ya les
locaux là l'univers de la faculté de
lettres par exemple se trouve dans le
bâtiment a absolument plus adapté aux
exigences d'à peu près trois mille
étudiants que se trouve dans ce bâtiment
puis il ya aussi des chants la question
que l'accès à l'université qu'on
considère qu'il est réservé aux enfants
des élites l'université me paraissait
premièrement antidémocratique totalement
et former des gens qui n'ont aucune idée
de ce qu'est la démocratie dans leur
pratique depuis l'enfance il n'y avait
pas de mixité il y avait c'était c'était
soit jeune et tais toi quoi vous savez
la fiche bien connu c'était exactement
ça il y avait la religion importante
c'était oppressant tout ça vraiment la
morale non on en avait marre vraiment
ras-le-bol on voulait casser ça voulait
pas prendre forcément le pouvoir on en
était incapable bien sûr un après les
événements suivants le monde it he may
mais mais on voulait au moins un peu
plus de liberté mi mars les étudiants de
sociologie se révoltent et réclame la
création d'une licence sur place on
raconte que la révolte tourangelle
serait le véritable déclencheur de
l'occupation du site de nanterre alors
légende ou réalité
c'est un but l'ensemble mouvement de mai
68 ça vient quand même de nanterre à
nanterre va déclencher ce mouvement est
ensuite atteindre toutes les universités
en france ce qui mettra véritablement le
feu aux poudres à tour c'est l'arrêt du
projet de construction d'un nouveau site
pour la faculté de lettres en bordure de
loire
coup de théâtre le 6 mai jean royer
décide d'annuler le projet en cours par
l'architecte albert qui a d'ailleurs
réalisé là la faculté de jussieu et
trouve que ce projet est vraiment trop
hideuse et c'est annulé en conseil
municipal le 8 mai 1968 le lendemain on
signe de désapprobation le doyen jacques
roger annonce publiquement sa démission
et à ce moment là les étudiants les
enseignants décident de manifester et à
ses slogans pour la construction d'une
université feu rajoute alto aux
violences policières suite aux
événements parisiens du 3 mai soudain la
mayonnaise a pris
je suis revenu le mardi 7 mai à la gare
de tours là j'ai posé mon sac je suis
reparti tout de suite sans manger
11h30 12h à la fac pour savoir ce qui se
passait et l'on m'a dit viens on va
mettre le bazar dans le cours d'un prof
de philo réac qui ne veut pas faire
cesser ces cours vient trotskiste mao
liste ou libertaire les étudiants
contestataires milite dans des courants
différents mais leur quartier général
est le même pour tous
le continental un café du centre-ville
le conti ce bar dans lequel nous sommes
là par l'état ce compte était un peu le
lieu de
rencontres et de retrouvailles de gens
de gauche entre guillemets c'était très
large une gauche très très large ça
allait du psu jusqu'à dml terre les
marxistes léninistes qui était l'est les
pro chinois de l'époque une seule où le
jeu vous car dans la journée un truc qui
ont loué la salle pour faire des
réunions de haut
c'était un soir les trotskistes très
vite un leader émergent chez les
étudiants tous rangés guthmann à
kaufmann qui est un barreau east et qui
donc aussi pas maxis plus tôt c'est en
ligne a cantonné temaru et ce temps
n'est qu'ils avaient des capacités
oratoires très développés ce qui
l'affecté dominer dans les assemblées
générales de l'université après un
passage quelques années plus tôt par les
instances du parti communiste la ligne
dure qu'il défende est alors l'avait
pourtant tenu à l'écart des premiers
soubresauts étudiants tout ça c'est des
petits bourgeois qui s'agitent et
laissons les petits bourgeois s'agiter
et pendant plusieurs semaines nous avons
été totalement hors du coup hors du coup
et c'est quand le mouvement a pris de
l'ampleur
et puis y compris socialement que à la
fois on s'est rendu compte de l'ampleur
du mouvement que d'une part ça n'était
pas uniquement un mouvement de deux
petits bourgeois et un moment donné
après on me propulse en me demandant
d'intervenir à partir de ce moment là
me voilà en mission l'agitation n'est
pas l'apanage des étudiants dans les
entreprises aussi règne une certaine
fébrilité avec des revendications tout
autre pour conserver les précieux
témoignages des luttes sociales la cgt a
créé son propre centre de recherche
l'institut d'histoire sociale et pour
ces chercheurs les événements de 68
constitue qu'une vraie mine d'or
on sent le
[Musique]
la montée des luttes qui a besoin de
s'exprimer de manière plus forte
68 n'est pas arrivée là tout seul on
faisait référence tout à l'heure en
regardant les littoral syndicalistes que
l'année 67 avait été très riche
d'ailleurs les statistiques du ministère
du travail montrent qu'ils plus d'heures
de grève en 67 kim y en a eu en 68
le malaise couvait déjà depuis longtemps
dans les entreprises et l'interdiction
de manifester à la date symbolique du
1er mai pour raison de sécurité
n'arrange rien pire la toute puissante
cgt bravent l'interdît et lance un appel
aux décide de franchir les murs et de
manifester dans les rues de tours ce qui
ce que c'est juste parce que derrière il
y avait une foule de manifestants et au
delà du camp cgt je peux dire c'est très
large devant la foule ils sont obligés
de céder quoi un succès qui allaient
préfigurer les normes mouvement du 13
mai où on a compté jusqu'à dix mille
manifestants dans les rues de tours déjà
les deux semaines précédentes avait été
émaillée de manifestations étudiantes
salariés du privé et du secteur public
défilent désormais aux côtés des
étudiants pour dénoncer la répression de
la police quelques jours plus tôt dans
la capitale
sachez de la plus grande manifestation à
toi depuis la libération
c'est donc à partir de cette date là que
les syndicats entre en scène
ici on traîne comme ailleurs il y avait
également des manifestations et des
défilés à amboise à chinon à loches
consentez un élan une possibilité un
avenir autre avec cette grève de 24
heures et cette grosse mobilisation le
13 mai constitue le véritable coup
d'envoi du grand mouvement social qui
avait agité la france pendant plus d'un
mois
dès le 13 mai au soir il y avait des
assemblées générales dans les
entreprises mais où les salariés poser
la question de la reconduction du
mouvement
et c'est parti le lendemain ça discute
beaucoup
eos et on commence à entendre que des
entreprises sont en grève et occupent
leur usine ont réuni l'intersyndicale et
au décide de rassembler le personnel en
fin de matinée pour prendre la décision
qui s'impose à notre avis la grève
générale et donc on procède par un vote
à bulletin secret et c'est une grande
majorité qui se prononce pour la nar
dans la plupart des entreprises les
événements s'accélèrent
après vont s'enchaîner à la la la grève
qui va débuter le 18 mai par la sncf et
ensuite qui va s'accélérer à partir du
20 mai c'était avant le temps des
réseaux sociaux et de la vidéo grand
public
jan bühlmann est alors jeune électricien
il se passionne pour le cinéma et
devient presque par hasard un témoin
privilégié des événements de la rue
je l'avais acheté chez un commerçant du
boulevard thiers le studio pierre et oui
ces conseils sont matériels mais j'étais
tout à fait le début et celle ci vous
servez à quoi cette caméra au départ
après j'avais acheté pour les vacances
une fois les vacances
j'imaginais pains qu'un jour je ferai un
historien gj 18 ans va éveiller les
voies région mais la caméra avec moi
mais j'avais même pas toutes été
improvisée
oui messieurs vous
cherchez la population toujours fait
émerger d'autres 2 avec des problèmes
différents mais ils sont ou seraient
retrouvés tous ensemble
très vite les lycéens entre eux aussi
dans la danse à partir de la mi mai ont
été mis en place les comités d'action
lycéens ils participaient aux
manifestations on les voit avec des
sortes de chapeaux en papier sur
lesquelles il ya les inscriptions au cal
et solidarité lycéens travailleurs c'est
surtout un lycée à tous qui est une
foyers de la contestation
ce paul louis courier et à petit de paul
louis courier c'est nous
ce mouvement s'est répandu et à
atteindre
on peut dire tous les lycées publics de
toi ça chauffe et mais bon nous moi
perso je ne pouvais pas me mêler à tout
ça pourquoi pas parce que ma mère était
enseignante et directrice d'une école et
mon père était gendarme donc pas fallu
que je sois dans une manifestation
alors comment vous faisiez vous
regardiez les gens avec un peu dans vie
ah bah oui
ah ben oui j'y serais bien allé oui
parce que c'était motivant à c'était
excitant aussi c'était vraiment leur
ruche ou n'occupe lycées c'était la rue
c'était génial comment d'occuper un lieu
de travail n'ont lieu d'être dépendant
faire complètement autre chose
fantastique et est donc le les salles de
cours c'était des sales valeron les avis
des corps et donc c'était là la salle
d'information générale donc on écoutait
la radio ou lisent les journaux longueur
de journée ce qu'on ne faisait pas avant
et puis on traduit j'ai tout ça pour
l'assemblée générale le soir pour moi
c'est une explosion cette big bang c'est
ce qui me permet de passer
une période de très près près mes 18 ans
une adolescente à un serpent monde aussi
pour moi c'est l'ouverture sur un autre
monde dans les entreprises les
motivations sont différentes mais le
mouvement s'étend et partout presque la
grève est votée hammam la greffe est
suivi à son poste
michelin a joué les tours et c'est un
cadre intéressant cas là vous avez
véritablement des grévistes contre les
non grévistes
avec 2 c'est même relativement violente
qui n'a pas encore été tout à fait
étudier ce qui fait que les
non-grévistes finalement impose la
reprise du travail après trois ou quatre
jours de grève
donc ensuite nous avons skf skfb des
faits assez bien suivie on s'est réunis
je le terre-plein central à l'entrée des
usines en dessous du grand jeu plus
grand saule pleureur d'abord qui avait
là à cette époque là et on a décidé à
main levée sous les acclamations
tout le monde a décidé de participer à
la grève est d'occuper les usines dans
les entreprises et s'organisent aucune
violence mais des piquets de grève très
efficace fallait aller dans devant les
entreprises et c'est le rôle justement
des rassemblements syndicaux où il ya
une photo justement très célèbre on voir
le rassemblement devant les usines
schmidt qui se trouvait rue du général
renault avec le syndicaliste qui parle
et les ouvriers avec leur béret
rassembler on a l'impression même un peu
mon jeu à 36 donc parce qu'il fallait
motiver quand même les gens pour
continuer à faire grève on allait
beaucoup dans les ateliers pour vous
rencontrer les travailleurs et donc ça
crée une ambiance et on avait aussi
beaucoup moins sans doute l'expérience
du passé qui faisait que chez kaddour on
était combatif quoi skf aussi il y avait
le directeur avait le droit de rentrer
mais sous surveillance des ouvres
et c'était un petit peu là là là
l'ouvrier fallait que le directeur
demande la permission de pouvoir rentrer
dans son entreprise mais pas besoin de
prendre des pavés pour toute façon les
gendarmes les fruits qu'ils étaient
occupés tellement ailleurs que nous on
pouvait tranquillement faire ce qu'on
voulait dans particulier dans
l'entreprise y avait pas de problème on
savait bien qu'il pourrait provenir
m'étais arrêté les matches chez nous
quoi dans les usines la grève s'installe
et puis entre grévistes et population on
re découvre même la solidarité
il y avait aussi des et des cultivateurs
qui venaient nous aider aussi
il y avait des quêtes en fait on a
installé des tournées de pommes de terre
pour les ramasser les pommes de terre
dans les fermes
enfin bonbons les salariés ne sont pas
en dehors de postes et df chemin de fer
dans le public aussi le blocage est
total
gérard le cheminot est chargé de tenir
un transformateur électrique à amboise
quand tu nous tiens d'ailleurs à 21h on
a fermé la station et on a tu peux plus
anciennes pouvait entrer dans ces
stations
alors on alimente et plus et cater peut
rien plaisir et à l'art est fait dans le
bâtiment 21 dans 124
on dit que les lieux étaient à 2 pour le
faire
l'une des originalités des événements de
ce printemps 68 c'est la présence très
active des femmes
longtemps resté dans l'ombre d'une
société où l'homme est tout puissant
elles se mettent elles aussi à
revendiquer leur place daniel alors
délégué syndical chez protex à
châteauroux nous on a souvent fait les
frais c'est vrai que j'étais presque une
avant-gardiste dans ce milieu rural et
je vous avoue que je ne me suis pas fait
bien voir du tout moi j'étais la meneuse
gt gt mal vu un y compris dans ma
famille où j'ai reçu des invectives
difficile mais j'ai jamais baisser les
bras car j'étais convaincue que les
femmes avaient leur place comme les
autres on se battait pour les planning
familial pour l'avortement on se battait
pour tout ça je pense que 68 a été pour
beaucoup notamment des femmes mais aussi
dans le milieu rural us à lisa réveiller
dans les manifestations étudiants et
ouvriers au coude à coude 2 montrent
pourtant si différents avec chacun ses
revendications propres mais avec une
même envie d'en découdre avait tout
pouvoir
je me suis senti beaucoup plus à l'aise
quand les ouvriers sont entrés dans le
mouvement parce que d'une part là
c'était pour moi un milieu connu sans
idéaliser mais il me paraissait je
dirais extraordinaire presque inespéré
qu'il y ait entre ces étudiants et les
ouvriers qu'il y ait une convergence de
lutte
on était vraiment comme des petits
enfants de choeur on souhaitait servir
la classe ouvrière
on voulait les écouter et ayant eu la
chance de faire des études
on voulait les aider dans leur pour les
libérer de ce qu'on appelait
l'oppression gaulliste l'oppression
capitaliste l'oppression impérialiste
etc
mais on était très mal reçue parce que
les appareils politiques traditionnels
surtout le pca ne voulait pas qu'on
marche sur ses plates bandes et disait
que on serait plus tard les exploitants
des ouvriers donc il nous mettait de
côté
j'avais toujours l'impression d'être un
petit peu de méfiance au niveau des
surtout des ouvriers que vous pas se
faire embarquer de quoi te voyais tous
les slogans de 68
bon il faut l'écrire togo boulot le
lendemain et ce avec après la grève
fallait qui pointe un pour ce qui est
des occupations de locaux la jeunesse
n'est pas en reste
jean des ponts l'étudiant en histoire à
noter ses moindres gestes dont deux
précieux petit carnet le vendredi 17 mai
je vois piquet de grève
prise de la fac c'est comme la prise de
la bastille coucher à la fac les
étudiants décident d'occuper la la fac
donc toujours ce bâtiment de la
grandière lac et place du 14-juillet à
tour et surtout aussi il accroche un
drapeau rouge et il rebaptise la place
qui s'appelle place du 14 juillet place
du 13 mai 1968 le lunetier réalisation
de l'occupation très forte
un petit peu comme la sorbonne d'un
point de vue symbolique
c'était essentiel c'était essentiel qu'à
partir du moment où on disait non à
l'université bourgeoise en occuper les
lieux de l'université on y travaille et
on préparait l'université de demain
le département compte jusqu'à 50000
grévistes à tour comme à paris
entreprise occupé éboueurs en grève
transports bloqués c'est toute la
société qui semble à l'arrêt alors
forcément la vie quotidienne devient un
peu plus difficile elle répond piste du
pôle tv janita acquérant des petites
vendée plus de 6 10 euros la religion c
est pour beaucoup
l'essence étaient rationnés donc julie à
l'avoir acheté pour la fin j'aime quand
on n'avait droit qu'à un certain quota
et simplement les médecins enfin les
services prioritaires avaient le droit
de prendre de l'essence mais apparemment
dans les magasins le ravitaillement
était quand même bien assurée enfin il
n'y a pas eu de crise de panique
les manifestations se succèdent pendant
qu'à paris durant tout le week end du 25
et 26 mai gouvernement et syndicats
négocient d'arrache-pied au matin du 27
mai à tours également les avants se sont
jugés insuffisants tic
on a eu des discussions avec la
direction après après le protocole
ronald et la direction elle bloquée à
10% au point de chant de salaire 10 %
donc il a fallu encore lutter pour
reprise de la lutte donc et nouvelle
manifestation le général de gaulle
reprend finalement la main et prononcé
son fameux discours du 30 mai avec une
annonce surprise
or les circonstances présentes je ne me
retirerai pas tout le monde s'attendait
à ce que de gaulle démissionne quand on
a entendu ce discours de combat parce
que c'était un discours de combat
ça prouve qu'on est véritablement dans
un grand rue tél 30 mais on a compris
qu'on était fichu je me souviens il ya
eu une soirée des deux de désespoir un
peu c'est le seul le soir on s'est
saoulé là le 30 mai après que de gaulle
ait parlé on a vu qu'ils partaient pas
que tout là tout le pouvoir de l'état
les flics la justice tout ça ça
resterait l'armée ça resterait et on
avait compris que non non la récréation
était terminée là le de gaulle sonné la
fin de la partie et que l'on avait
intérêt à mettre maintenant faire mourir
le mouvement laisser mourir le mouvement
et le lendemain dans mon carnet gelé
noter on s'ennuie j'ai noté rien le on
s'ennuie même j'ai marqué on savait que
c'était fini
[Musique]
galvanisé par les propos du général et
par la démonstration de force du 30 mai
dans les rues de la capitale
les gaullistes touvent jour organisent
leurs propres manifestations de soutien
quelques jours plus tard malgré tous les
efforts qui ont été faits il n'y a qu'à
peu près de 2000 personnes qui se
rassemblent donc devant l'hôtel de ville
ça commence par une allocution de jean
royer et à l'issue de ce rassemblement
les étudiants donc qu liste est un
groupe de l'extrême droite décide de
prendre le boulevard heurteloup et
d'aller jusqu'à la fac de lettres la
grandière place du 14 juillet est en
fait d'aller à l'assaut de de cette fac
occupée
on est en train de prendre un peu au
conti et puis on voit arriver des
drapeaux bleu blanc rouge tout plein
c'est quoi des fachos qu'est ce qui se
passe alors est en effet arrivé là des
voitures de toute la touraine
apparemment avec des drapeaux et puis je
pourrais y crier vive de gaulle enfin
alors on s'est levés spontanément des
gares défi et puis on s'est mis à crier
vont contre e1 bien sûr les flics se
sont mis entre les deux groupes et les
jeunes manifestants voyant qu'ils
pourraient pas nous nous repousser les
flics toute façon faisait un barrage
utile ce sont tout d'un coup à courir
avec leurs drapeaux pour aller prendre
la grandière qui était occupé encore par
quelques camarades alors on a couru
derrière eux boulevard béranger
ils ont pris la rue de la grandière on a
remonté plus vite qu'eux et non et on
est arrivé face à face devant la porte
de la grande guerre échange d'invectivés
de projectiles les assaillants
parviennent même à décrocher le fameux
drapeau rouge si symbolique
pénètre au rez de chaussée ils prennent
des documents il faut un petit peu de
joie avec les documents ils attaquent un
petit peu les les étudiants et
finalement ils sont délogés par la
police
à 20h et donc la fac est évacuée par les
étudiants qu'il occupait en fait c'est
la fin de l'épisode violent du mai 68
tourangeaux dans les entreprises comme
chez les étudiants le mouvement
s'essouffle peuple ça s'est désagrégé
lentement chacun a rejoint son bercail
on était un peu vide
les lampions s'éteignent et la fête
était finie
en habile courant sur la caténaire à la
reprise et puis voilà
la mode est bloquée porte à penser tous
les roms était rouillé il a fait passer
être la meilleure pour que les circuits
doigt puis cet effet puis sur leurs
effets et puis voilà les cas douteux
reprennent en fanfare ce sont les
derniers salariés de touraine à renouer
avec le travail
nous sommes le 24 juin 1968
le matin même tout le monde attendait
devant la porte de luz une personne ne
rentrait et quelques camarades qu'on
lançait le champ et c'est parti en
rentrant quel charme de quelque chose
là-bas il y avait la marseillaise il y
avait tout l'international c'était une
ambiance familiale quoi
l'amertume de ne pouvoir aller au bout
des rêves existe mais pour beaucoup les
bénéfices sont bien réelles ont obtenu
après le mouvement le temps de croiser
quelques % d'augmentation
avant on vivait chichement par maman
augmentation des salaires -notamment du
smic qui bondit de 35% rapprochement des
40 heures facilités accordées aux
syndicats au sein même des entreprises
les avancées sont nombreuses médéa qui
vit aux événements de 68 consacre
surtout un changement profond de société
la liberté ouais c'est ça surtout la
liberté de parole d'h quelque part aussi
d'agir avant
c'est dans la société et le lendemain
ils avaient l'impression dans son volet
du point de vue de l'imaginaire du point
de vue du jeu de l'invention star je
pense qu'on est qu'on a on a fait
beaucoup
je pense que la condition de la femme
c'est quand même beaucoup améliorée
grâce à ça donc il y avait des victoire
68 a été un terreau dans ces milieux
ruraux on n'avait pas l'habitude de
militer de faire des grèves de faire des
mouvements
il ya eu un exemple et ça a mûri je
crois aussi que mai 68 nous à nous a
sorti de là chaque gaullistes on nous
demandait d'être silencieux demande au
pays des deux sages et puis il y avait
le maître qu'il fallait écouter
bon tout ça ça a volé en éclats en
revanche je crois qu'il ya des peurs qui
sont revenus très vite et qu'en
particulier avec la fin des trente
glorieuses
tout d'un coup on s'est mis peu à peu de
manière insidieuse puis après
ouvertement accusé mai 68 et ces deux
mots qui n'étaient pas les siens
aubras temps et aujourd'hui que
reste-t-il de ses rêves et de ses acquis
dans le quotidien des tourangeaux
quelque chose
moi à 75 ans j'ai l'impression que mon
combat de 50 ans mais reste pratiquement
plus rien je vois que l'on entend dans
tous les services publics en l'air et ça
devrait bien commencer un mouvement
comme ça parce que toute série celui qui
fout le camp et aux prophéties aux
profits records des actionnaires et tout
ça qu'est-ce qui reste bas il reste pas
mal de choses
en tout cas sur sur la culture un peu de
la lutte parce que c'était quand même ce
qui en sort le plus du côté du monde du
travail à l'esprit de solidarité de deux
conquêtes sociales puisqu'il ya eu des
grandes avancées par contre il ya des
choses qui restent - notamment des
grèves avocats avec occupation ça
faisait ça fait bien longtemps qu'on n'a
pas vu je n'ai jamais supporté qu'on
salisse mai 68 parce que parce que les
rêves de mai 68 c'était pas des petits
rêves c'était pas des petits règles
comme
[Musique]
et